what's happening with captain marvel
what's next for captain marvel
gosh so much going on a lot of really
juicy things happening that i cannot say
a word about not a word but boy oh boy
that's brie larson teasing fans during
an appearance on siriusxm's the jess
cagle show about what's to come in the
captain marvel sequel actually titled
the marvels larson also teased the scope
of the sequel in another interview with
sirius xm stars
it's it's a really unique experience i'm
a huge fan of disneyland and so to me it
feels like i get to go to my own like
private disneyland every single day
because they're building all these
insane
worlds that like wow no one else knows
about no one else gets to see i mean
you'll see it when when when the movie
comes out but for now it's just mine
like i i'm in like sets that are bigger
than you could imagine right now and
it's really special now not officially
announced to return to the sequel samuel
l jackson surprised fans with a
behind-the-scenes look at shooting
sharing photos of an epic mustache and
beard combo along with an equally epic
t-shirt
fans know what that is
the marvels will also reunite larsen's
carol danvers with the monica rambo we
know and love from wand division played
by tiana paris as well as mcu newcomer
canadian actress iman valani who will be
introduced to the world as miss marvel
in her own series on disney plus
the marvels is currently shooting and
set to be released in november 2022
fingers crossed will all be able to see
that together in theaters
now i've been hoping for a while now
that there's a possibility of wolverine
clawing his way into the mcu
especially after hugh jackman went viral
for his photo with marvel president
kevin feige
well it turns out those hopes have been
slashed
for now in an interview with jake
hamilton for jake's takes jackman says
that wolverine entering the multiverse
isn't on the table is there a story
angle or a pitch under that multiverse
umbrella that could convince you to
reprise wolverine
well
the fact jake that i'm hearing about
this from you
and there's nothing in my inbox from
kevin feige means it's probably no
matter what idea i came up with
not on the table let's just be clear
there but
now i
i realized
before we shot logan
i was like
we got the idea we knew what it was
going to be
ish right
and i thought this is it and that really
helped me it really helped knowing i was
going into my last season that it was my
last season that i made the most of it
and it's still
a character i hold close to my heart
but i know it's done tell tell that to
it whoever you want but please tell it
to ryan because he's like doesn't
believe anything so i'm joking please
i'll tell i'll call him i'll call him
i'll call i don't want this to be true
ryan just don't take that call
now moving on from mutants to the caped
crusader himself michael keaton is
revealing that it felt shockingly normal
to step back into the bat suit in
another interview with jake my man
they're always doing the good ones
keaton talks about reprising his role as
the batman in andy muscati's upcoming
the flash film it was shockingly
normal it was weird
and like i went
oh
oh yeah that's right um
but also as then you start to
play the scenes it was um like a lot of
memories a lot of a lot of memories a
lot of really interesting like sense
memories actually
it's like muscle memory
is it like a muscle member yeah actually
have you said the words i'm batman yet i
can't i can't i can't hear you wearing a
we're having a uh
an ifb issue
i hate when that happens hot on the
heels of marvel's multiverse dc's the
flash will be taking a step into
different dimensions as well seeing both
keaton and ben affleck as batman and
speaking of batman one of his proteges
tim drake aka robin or red robin is
making headlines of his own
tim drake surprised fans in this week's
issue of batman urban legends when he
said yes to going on a date with bernard
the story of some of our parts created
by writer megan fitzmartin and artist
belen ortega shows robin trying to
defeat a mysterious new villain who has
captured his old friend the story also
shares that tim is wrestling with his
personal identity something fitzgerald
was thrilled to tackle i wanted to pay
tribute to the fact that sexuality is a
journey if it's martin said in an
interview with polygon adding tim is
still figuring himself out i don't think
he has the language for it all yet
so it looks like fans will have to
continue reading new issues to see how
tim's journey goes but it's clear that
many are excited to have another lgbtq
plus character in the bat family well
that's it for me and i hope you enjoyed
those headlines what surprised you most
as always drop your thoughts in the
comments below
you